welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness this week along
with a new trailer in tickets now on
sale at least for the faster trigger
fingers on amc's app dropped five new
official posters each of them
beautifully designed and filled with
interesting details and easter eggs i'm
gonna break down all five of these
posters because analyzing all this
movies marketing is the reason mephisto
put me on this earth and because i i
love you okay the five new posters
include the theatrical poster the imax
poster the dolby poster the real 3d
poster in the screen x poster let's
start with a theatrical poster this
poster uses the same broken glass
aesthetic from the poster that came out
in february both harking back to the
broken class motif from what if the way
the watcher of that series depicted the
barriers between realities in the
multiverse the main characters are all
arranged in a circle strange in the 12
o'clock position doing the same go
longhorns hand sign that chris hemsworth
is doing at thor love and thunder we're
finally promoting this movie post it's
all connected but needs strange's hand
is wang then gargantos then wanda with
her head directly beneath the eye of
agamotto then america chavez and a star
portal hovering right over strange's
palm in the lower corner of that poster
pamertaj and a red tinted filter casting
it as the battle site of this film then
variant dr christine palmer and her
illuminati lab coat and then mordo
supreme now interesting to note this
poster lists michael stuhlbarg in the
top billing who plays dr nicodemus west
in the 2016 film and in this movie who
so far has only shown up in promo
footage at christine palmer's wedding
now dr west has a really big role in the
amazing comic story line the oath it
might have an expanded role in this
movie but also the exact order and
listing of the film billing is something
negotiated in actors contracts depending
on how pushy their agents are now if
you've been watching these videos for a
while you know a big part of my job is
trying to translate other texts or
symbols that are on screen something i
always try to do in my real life with
real world languages and a life's
mission that i've been able to work
towards thanks to help from our video
sponsor today babel babel is the number
one language learning app in the world i
live in california where a lot of people
speak a lot of non-english languages and
i'm jealous of the multi-linguistic
is that a word i should at least know
english i just want to add some multi to
my own linguisticity in 2022 and finally
learn spanish and unbabel is helping me
out with that babble specializes in
preparing you for real life encounters
and situations it also has no ads
because those are real life encounters
i'm already getting plenty of today's
lesson
no preguntas nailed it i just like how
they gamify the learning process i got
daily goals and achievements and i can
unlock as i learn the language i played
around with learning through an app
before but the free apps just seemed too
basic university studies have shown that
15 hours of using babble is the
equivalent of a semester of college
spanish i'm pretty early in my babble
journey but i have started to learn some
useful phrases like chaoses
which translates to what do you do in
your free time and i'm on my way to
making some friends already some very
very patient friends so get 65 off your
subscription when you click the link in
the description to start learning with
babble today now also as before those
broken shards all contain other variants
will be seen throughout the movie to the
right of strange's head as a variant
with a thicker goatee which might be
sinister strange who now in the trailer
has a third eye to his right is defender
strange i think because defender strange
has a thinner mustache and that kind of
soul patch and then a thinner chin strap
of course the pull back hair but into
his right is that same defender strange
when he takes on his zombified form in
that mountaintop battle with the demon
arm splayed out behind him in the images
of icon pose to his right is wanda i
think his loungewear wando with the
blood streaming down her face from that
super bowl trailer and beneath her is a
shard showing a cleaner faced wanda now
on the left side of this poster on
either sides of mortar's stream are
again that broken watch face from the
december trailer on the left and then
another form of wanda on the right now a
little detail about that watch that i
have failed to mention sorry in the
shots of the hatch opening to that
utopian parallel looking location
strange has strapped that broken watch
on the knob of that hatch crazy that
watch was given to him by christine
palmer in the 2016 film and then broke
when muggers attacked him and then in
the film's final shot it served as a
lasting symbol of strange's unhealable
wound of his broken hands but his
mastery of the mental and the mystical
over the physical now it is being used
practically as a kind of key to open
back doors through dimensions maybe
strange himself set up this store as a
failsafe in a worst-case scenario when
he would need to access that hidden item
that he kept in this place or since
variant christine is right next to him
there and she's the one who gave him the
watch in an alternate timeline it could
be a bell safe that she set up above
these is a shard showing the illuminati
panel but unlike in the trailer all the
slots appeared to be filled with that
one last figure walking up to their seat
maybe mortar supreme as we saw in the
trailer all of these filled including
the empty space between the middle two
chairs that we assume will be occupied
by charles xavier's hover chair now to
the right of this is defender strange
again the silver stripe more clearly
visible let's move on to the imax poster
which overall has this really cool look
with the broken pieces showing different
faces of the variants of strange and
wanda mordo wong and america but all
arranged like daggers pointing inward at
strange's face or maybe even the teeth
of some supernatural being devouring him
now among these variants is the rotting
face of defender strange which is just
looking more and more sam raimi evil
dead with every new promo that comes out
one little unnerving detail in this
poster that i love notice how pretty
much all of the eyes in these shards are
looking directly at us but when you
reassemble the shard on the far right
which shows wanda with her fiery red
hair and then the matching one on the
far left of wanda with the same hair
color one of her eyes looks at us while
the other looks askew this whole one eye
on us the other not effect is a freaky
horror trick that bill skarsgard pulled
off practically as pennywise in it and
it casts wanda as a similar potential
horror villain it also reflects how this
wanda really has split forms with each
form having her eyes on different prizes
one helping strange the other helping
herself now the dolby poster might be my
favorite because it's really the
simplest newer visuals really just the
sound of it baby strange investigates a
sanctum window that's been blown open by
some intrusive force with red tinted
glow but then on the floor behind him
that intruder is already in the house
the shadow of the scarlet witch creeping
up on him now the real 3d poster plays
up the variance in the symmetry visual
themes at the top is strange with his
variants fanning out from him on either
sides like a rolodex on the right it
looks like sinister strange or some
other version and then on the left
defender strange in a way these two
variants embody the classic trope of the
angel versus the demon on either
shoulder from strange's perspective the
angel defender strange on his right
shoulder associated with good and then
the demon sinister strange on his left
shoulder associated with evil beneath
them are variant dr christine palmer and
her echoes mordo supreme and his echoes
and then wong in his echoes with the
scarlet witch in the center
interestingly a singular figure
orchestrating all this madness the one
spinning the rolodexes and then at the
bottom america chavez in a red-colored
new york street as the tentacles of
garganto snake out after her but then on
the left a site the sanctorum with some
figure standing in front of it is it
mnope is actually the statue of the
clean-shaven supreme strange that we saw
in the earlier trailer whom i have
always seen is suspicious because what
the main person erects a huge statue in
their own honor other than someone who
can't erect anything else by the way
today's sponsor is just kidding we
already did that now lastly there is the
screen x poster which also showcases all
the main figures and their variants he
has strange in the center with four
variants one on the left and then three
on the right the middle of those being
the defender strange and then below on
the right is gargantos and then between
him and wanda is some red lit ruins
maybe the twisted tree background behind
wanda and strange when she drops the
facade of her orchard pocket reality and
then to the left of wanda is kamar taj
and then wang and america dr christine
palmer the mortar supreme and then the
upper left of mordo the illuminati deus
once again with strange standing before
it now beside america is this pedestal
that i spotted in my trailer breakdown
of the ruins of i think america's home
dimension utopian parallel a pedestal
that in the trailer showed a glowing
blue item now here confirmed to be a
book now that may be the dark hold or it
could be some other book used to
counteract the darkhold like the book of
bishanti which in the comics is used to
counteract curses with only protective
magic which would be a pretty important
item for strange in america and
christine to seek out to undo the
madness that wanda and the darkhold have
unleashed across the multiverse now that
it's showing up both in the trailer and
this poster so prominently it tells us
that this book whatever it is is going
to be key to the movie's plot you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow me rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more announcements of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you